you are one of the seminal figures in
the history of neural networks
at the intersection of cognitive
psychology and computer science
what do you has over the decades emerged
as the most beautiful aspect about
neural networks
both artificial and biological
the fundamental thing i think about with
neural networks is how they allow us to
link
biology
with
the mysteries of thought and
um
you know in the
when i was first entering the field
myself in
the late 60s early 70s
cognitive psychology had just become a
field there was a book published in 67
called cognitive psychology
and the author
said that
you know the study of the nervous system
was only of peripheral interest it
wasn't going to tell us anything about
the mind
and i
didn't
agree with that i i always felt oh look
i'm i'm a physical
being i
from dust
to dust you know ashes to ashes and
somehow i emerged from that
um so that's really interesting so there
was a sense with cognitive
psychology that
in understanding the sort of neuronal
structure of things you're not going to
be able to understand the mind
and then your senses if we study these
neural networks we might be able to get
at least very close to understanding the
fundamentals of the human mind yeah
i used to think um where i used to talk
about the idea of awakening from the
cartesian dream
so descartes
um
you know thought about these things
right
he
he was walking in the gardens of
versailles one day and he stepped on a
stone and a statue moved
and he walked a little further stepped
on another stone and another statue
moved and he like
why did the statue move when i stepped
on the stone and he went and talked to
the gardeners and he found out that they
had a hydraulic system
that allowed
the physical contact with the stone to
cause water to flow in various
directions which caused water to flow
under the statue and move the statue
and
he
used this as
the beginnings of a theory about how
animals
act
and
he had this notion that
these little fibers that people had
identified that weren't carrying the
blood
you know were these little hydraulic
tubes that if you touch something there
would be pressure and it would send a
signal of pressure to the other parts of
the system and that would cause action
so he had a mechanistic theory of
animal behavior
and he thought that the human
had this animal
body
but that some
divine something else had to have come
down and been placed in him
to give him the ability to think
right so
the physical world includes the body in
action but it doesn't include thought
according to descartes right
and so the study of physiology at that
time was the study of sensory systems
and motor systems and
things that you could
directly measure when you stimulated
neurons and stuff like that
and
the study of cognition was something
that
you know was tied in with abstract
computer algorithms and things like that
but when i was an undergraduate i
learned about the physiological
mechanisms
and so when i'm studying cognitive
psychology as a first year phd student
i'm saying
wait a minute the whole thing is
biological
you had that intuition right away that
seemed obvious to you yeah
yeah
it's not magical though that from just
the little bit of biology can emerge the
full beauty of the human experience is
that
why is that so obvious to you well i it
obvious
and not obvious at the same time um and
i think about darwin in this context too
because
darwin
knew very early on that none of the
ideas that anybody had ever offered
gave him a sense of understanding how
evolution
could have worked
he wanted to figure out how it could
have worked that was his goal
and
he
spent a lot of time
working on this idea and coming you know
reading about things that gave him hints
and thinking they were interesting but
not knowing why and
drawing more and more pictures of
different birds that differ slightly
from each other and so on you know and
and then then he figured it out
but after he figured it out he had
nightmares about it
he would dream about the complexity of
the eye
and the arguments that people had given
about how ridiculous it was to imagine
that
that could have ever emerged from some
sort of you know
unguided process right that it hadn't
been the product of design
and and uh so he he didn't publish for a
long time in part because he was
scared of his own ideas he didn't think
they could probably possibly be true
yeah
but then you know by the time
the 20th century rolls around we all
uh
you know we understand that evolut or
many people understand or believe
that evolution uh produced you know the
entire uh range of uh animals that there
are
uh and uh you know descartes idea starts
to seem a little wonky after a while
right like well wait a minute
um
there's
the apes and the chimpanzees and the
bonobos and you know like they're pretty
smart in some ways you know so what
oh you know somebody comes oh there's a
certain part of the brain that's still
different they don't you know there's no
hippocampus in the
monkey brain it's only in the human
brain
uh huxley had to do a surgery in front
of many many people in the late 19th
century to show to them there's actually
a hippocampus
in the chimpanzee spraying you know
so so their continuity of the species is
another
element uh that you know contributes
to um
this sort of you know
idea that we are
ourselves uh a total product of nature
um and uh
that to me is the is the magic in the
mystery how
how nature could actually um
you know give rise to
uh
organisms that have the uh capabilities
that we have
so it's interesting because even the
idea of evolution is hard for me to keep
all together in my mind so because we
think of a human time scale
it's hard to imagine that like like the
the development of the human eye would
give me nightmares too
because you have to think across many
many many generations
and it's very tempting to think about
kind of a growth of a complicated object
and it's like how is it possible for
that such
such a thing to be built because also
me from a robotics engineering
perspective it's very hard to build
these systems how can through an
undirected process can a complex thing
be designed it seems not it seems wrong
yeah so that's absolutely right and i
you know um a slightly different career
path that would have been equally
interesting to me would have
would have been um to actually study the
process of
embryological development
flowing on into
brain development and the
um
exquisite sort of laying down of
pathways and so on that occurs in the
brain and i know the slightest bit about
that it's not my field but
um
there are
you know fascinating
aspects to this process that
eventually result in the
you know the complexity of of uh
various brains
at least you know one thing um we're
um
in in the field i think people have felt
for a long time
in the study of vision the continuity
between
humans and non-human animals has been
has been second nature for a lot longer
i was having i had this conversation
um with somebody who's a vision
scientist and you're saying oh we we
don't have any problem with this you
know the monkey's visual system and the
human visual system extremely similar
um
up to certain levels of course they they
diverge after a while but the first
the the visual pathway from the eye to
the brain and the first few
layers of
cortex um or cortical areas i guess one
would say
are extremely similar
you